this is fascinating to me you became
addicted to the hair plugs and you said
that they put you out they put you under
for uh the operation
right because you had many operations
yeah i had i had a total of eight
a total of eight and when you first have
them they couldn't put you up
they couldn't make you unconscious well
they didn't tell me that and and so
the first time i had it and by the way i
know sal has has gone down this
god-awful path
yes it is barbaric are you sorry you
ever got started with it no i'm thankful
okay i'm thankful even after what i went
through which i'll get to in a second
so the fallacy is that once you get a
hair plug that it will stay forever
it doesn't work well you have to you
have to continue that once you hook in
that's the trick i mean you've seen
people who have had one are like screw
this this hurts i mean it's
painful and then they have like like
barbie doll head yeah
exactly you have to fill in around all
that stuff
so that was kind of the joke in my book
like i'm addicted to pain
i'm not addicted to pain i'm not it's
awful but things went horribly wrong
in that and this to me would be
devastating you went in for an operation
i don't know if it was your eighth one
or whatever it was the last it was
the last one you go in they put you out
when you wake up your voice was
paralyzed you didn't have a voice
when you go under they put a tube down
your throat
to allow you to breathe yes in case
anything goes wrong they have it they
have an airway
into you well then they put a cuff they
inflate a cuff around that
tube to hold it in place well when
they're working on my head
for this stupid surgery right they're
moving my head and neck around
and that cuff sat on the nerve
that's responsible for firing my left
vocal cord so i come out of this surgery
and i'm like this yeah and i was like
this for
because only your vocal cords yes come
together they vibrate they vibrate they
come together well one was laying over
here
so you can't keep air i couldn't talk to
you like this
if my life depended did they think this
could have been a permanent condition
yeah
were you flipping the [ __ ] out i i went
into depression i was going through a
divorce this was right after
i've done this will be the fifth super
bowl i'm doing this sunday
wow and this was after the third one i
did
so that was in february this all happens
at the end of february into march
and i've got a baseball season that's
about to start and i
i can't say a complete sentence now
you're gonna have hair and no reason for
it right so i run
into one of your guests mcconaughey at
this event down in cabo
and i tell him about this procedure
right maybe poking around for
information from him we'll leave that
for another day
so i say to him uh you know i'm like hey
uh
he's like what's up with your voice
there buckaroo yeah and i said uh
well i went in for a uh a hair plug
procedure and uh they put a tube down my
throat
and when i came out i i had this because
i told the story and he goes hmm
so what you're saying is you fixed your
video
but [ __ ] up your audio yeah
great thanks for being so careful and
then he's like on to the next thing
so that yeah i i i was so i'm going
through a divorce
i'm a stress ball anyway that's how i
live my life
yep i think i'm done because of this
stupid procedure
right and i've got a lot of people that
depend on me to earn the living
yeah that i earn and i've got a baseball
season that's coming up
which leads to the football season which
the and i'm what do you tell your bosses
at fox do you come i told them i had a
virus right you didn't want to tell them
what else no i it's embarrassing yeah
and i don't want to you know you tell
your bosses then it gets to the pr guy
well then it leaks out and it's i don't
know why
it's embarrassing to tell somebody that
you had hair plugs because it's kind of
like the world sees that as a frivolous
uh operation oh they're right but
they're right but you know what you're
on tv
and if you look old they don't [ __ ]
hire you yeah i i kind of i have a
as i joke before i have a massive head
i did the public a favor i covered
portions of my head
with hair from the back of my head